actor comedian and commercial pitchman
Paul Hogan won a Golden Globe and an
Oscar nomination for his role in the
extremely popular 1986 comedy Crocodile
Dundee the movie earned 328 million
dollars worldwide and its sequel brought
in another 239 million making Hogan one
of the biggest stars of the 80s but he
never quite made a name for himself
internationally outside of playing the
role that made him famous so whatever
happened to Crocodile Dundee marriage
problems Hogan was married to his first
wife noeleen for nearly 30 years
but while Hogan was making Crocodile
Dundee he fell in love with his
on-screen romantic interest American
actress Linda Kozlowski he divorced
noeleen married Kozlowski in 1990 and
the pair had a son together expanding a
family that already included Hogan's
five children with his first wife their
marriage lasted for well over 20 years
but it eventually ended when Kozlowski
filed for divorce in 2013 citing that
they grew apart was also because she was
tired of living in her husband's shadow
who knew that Hogan even cast a shadow
in 2013 he declined huge movies some
actors have the luxury of making only
the movies and shows they really want to
make and Hogan thought that he fit that
description dating back to his early
days as a writer and star of his own TV
show Hogan liked to have creative
control and he rejected a number of
projects that could have advanced his
career he turned down the lead role in
ghosts to make his own movie about a
ghost almost an angel ghost cast Patrick
Swayze and was a smash hit but you
probably haven't even heard of what
Hogan ended up doing
is almost an injury for a guy with
Academy Award nominations a major movie
franchise and an Oscars hosting stint
under his belt Hogan has shockingly few
credits to his name apart from his
Crocodile Dundee films and almost an
angel he starred in just four other
feature films lightning Jack flipper
strange bedfellows and Charlie and boots
the last two weren't even commercially
released in the United States by 1989
America had already moved on to fellow
Australian Yahoo serious anyhow now
Australia's colossal comedy hit starring
its newest comedy hero comes to the
States and we all saw how that turned
out just a few years later I know those
words but that sign makes non cent
entrepreneur back in 1993 crowdfunding
wasn't really a thing so Hogan created
the first ever film trust to fund his
cowboy comedy lightning Jack and placed
it on the Australian Stock Exchange the
trust raised 35 million Australian
dollars and investors were to see a
payout after seven years however there
probably weren't too many profits to go
around lightening Jack was a box-office
bomb
despite it being one of Cuba Gooding jr.
earliest big-screen roles
earning back about half of the money it
had raised as scheduled the lightning
Jack film trust was delisted from the
Australian Stock Exchange in 2001 but
Hogan was decades ahead of his time in
his approach to funding films take that
Zach Braff Crocodile Dundee 3 later
after the characters popularity peaked
in the late 80s
Hogan brought back Crocodile Dundee one
more time for 2001 s Crocodile Dundee in
Los Angeles it earned just 25 million in
the US and more surprisingly only 7
million in Hogan's native Australia
critics hated it and it later earned a
Razzie Award nomination for worse to
remake or sequel Matthew berry one of
the film's writers told the podcast how
did this get made that he and writing
partner Eric Abrams pitch their idea for
a third Dundee film to Hogan he approved
it and the writers came back three
months later with a screenplay and
that's when things got weird
basically he then rewrites all pretty
much the entire script he throws a
couple of new things in there while the
general plot was unchanged
Hogan claimed it rewrote so much so he
should be the
only credited screenwriter and
subsequently the only writer who would
receive residuals the writers guild
wound up ruling in favor of the original
writers and hogan protested the decision
if hogan ever wants to bring the
character back to the screen
he needs to offer Berrien Abrams the
option to write the script
how does Crocodile Dundee goes to hell
sound tax trouble after his name came up
in a 2005 government investigation into
offshore tax havens Hogan battled
Australia over millions and allegedly
unpaid taxes a closer look at the actors
finances found evidence that he hadn't
paid taxes on more than 37 million
earned dating back to 1986
although Hogan lived in the US and paid
American taxes during much of that time
he was still considered an Australian
citizen and was not only their tourism
spokesperson but 1985's Australian of
the Year come and say g'day
I'll slip an extra shrimp on the barbie
for you in 2010 Hogan left his home in
the US to attend his mother's funeral in
Sydney Australia where tax officials
served him with papers preventing him
from leaving the country until his case
could be resolved the matter was settled
after two years of mediation and the
confidential terms which probably
involved a didgeridoo and a couple of
koalas
he took his show on the road in 2013
Hogan returned to performing and writing
with a comical biographical one-man show
in which he talked about his colorful
life so how much of this new show have
you prepared it's it's touring in
november/december where are you at this
opportunity how am i working on it for
like 40 years
an evening with hogs was a huge success
selling out dates around Australia Hogan
brought back the tour for another string
of appearances hogs live in 2015
retired by the time Hogan found
international success of Crocodile
Dundee in 1986 he was 47 years old a
late bloomer to say the least he'd been
working in entertainment for well over a
decade at that point he since jokes that
he works less because he's instituted a
self-imposed exile whatever he wants to
call it Hogan is now pushing 80 a
perfectly reasonable time to slow down a
bit we'll always have his glowing
endorsement of Australia ways to make
okay he's Australian maybe I better go
there someday thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you're loved too
[Music]